yo what's up guys it's marcus brownlee
here from mkbhd
i got another hd tutorial for you guys
this was not actually a requested video
but i put a request in the title because
this has actually been uh asked by a
number of people um whether it was from
youtube messaging or from contacting me
through a website uh they've actually
asked me over here on the right hand
side how i got these colored icons over
my folders or actually to be the icon of
the folder and i'm going to show you how
to do that right now so
first thing you want to do is open up
your internet browser and
any internet browser does work for this
as long as you're comfortable
downloading and you can go to basically
any uh internet br any uh popular search
engine and type in uh icon pack and the
first link will be iconspeedia.com
and i'll go ahead and throw that link in
the description so you guys don't need
to remember it but basically on this
website is where you can get what pretty
much where you can get any of your icons
um they have featured icon packs uh
individual icons such as these random
icons and if you go ahead and click on
an icon pack you can see
that there are 109 icons in this you
know here's all these
all these files now you can either
download as an ico or an icon file or
just as a png image
so you can also search in the left-hand
side from um all sorts of different
icons uh different styles things you
might want to uh check out putting on
your uh on your icon so once you've
found one you like and you actually
download it you don't have to install it
after you've downloaded it just remember
where you have it so i remember i saved
mine right here and i named it mac os 10
icons so i have all the i
ico files and all the dot png files and
i also have a readme which i could
probably delete
so i've noticed this works for
especially well for folders so we're
going to just find a folder on my
desktop here i want to change i don't
have that much on my desktop but here's
a folder of stuff that was just on the
camera 2.75 gigs of stuff in a folder i
don't really use we're just going to
right click it and go to properties
and once we've gone to properties we can
actually go to the customize tab all the
way on the right hand side and here's
where we can say what kind of folder do
you want folder pictures etc
on the bottom here it says folder icons
and you can change the folder icon if
you change it it'll no longer show a
preview of the folder's contents but it
will still have a pretty cool looking
image we're going to hit the change icon
button
and here there's you know a bunch of
actually numerous built-in icons into
windows vista but i don't really like
any of these and i'd rather use my own
that i downloaded so just go ahead and
hit the browse button
and uh once you hit the browse button
you're gonna have to go ahead and
remember where you saved those icons so
i'm just going to find them
are right in here mac os 10 icons and
you can select the dot icon file or the
dot png file it doesn't really matter
but the dot icon file is a little bit
smaller
if that makes a difference to you i pick
a color i guess i'll choose a blue one
and just go ahead and pick uh the icon
that you downloaded and i'll search i'll
use this icon and i'll hit the ok button
make sure you hit apply and then hit ok
and there you go that's that's your icon
right there so now it's the same title
and everything except it has that um
that cool uh a movie looking uh folder
that i've downloaded from the website so
i hope this tutorial was helpful to you
guys maybe you want to go ahead and
custom your desktop now if you uh really
like the icons you see on that website
again the link is in the description and
i guess that's basically it so thanks
for watching this hd tutorial if you
have any questions or comments just go
ahead and leave them below if you need a
request video done go ahead and
subscribe and send me a message and i'll
try to get to you with a request video
so thanks for watching this one and have
a nice night peace